with every game with every challenge  this team just gets better and better  what stood out to you about their  performance today they outplayed us at  start of the second half they got it to  five  and after the time out  we were a different team  going zone helped us  but we scored two straight times and  that was that was big  you talked to us about wanting this so  bad for your team to see them right now  have the opportunity i'm so happy yeah  we call it crossing the bridge  there's nothing  like being a regional champ  and going to final four and playing on  that saturday  with three other champions it's an  amazing day  i know there's a motion but for you to  be able to continue this run in your  final season i'm not i'm on their bus  i'm on their bus they're not on my and  mike yo you should interview him this is  the goal right here no no shut up i'm  gonna interview both of you guys